bravo sie haben eine falle gestellt ich
hab's dir gezeigt junge du wusstest es
nicht wann service kis und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video hat mich
sehr gefreut dass die letzte folge
akinator ich so gut gefallen hat heute
gibt es eine neue und ich habe heute
eine ganz besondere person die ich heute
beraten werde
und ich möchte mich gerne eines spielers
ortsteil und zwar ratet mal mit während
der akinator mir die fragen beantwortet
ratet mal mit und versucht zu erraten
wer sein könnte der gesucht ist es ist
nicht so weit entfernt ist es recht
naheliegend die sache aber es ist ich
bin gespannt ob der akinator drauf kommt
ich weiß es nicht
es könnte sein es könnte aber auch sehr
gut nicht sein also wir schauen einfach
mal und ihr schreibt doch einfach mal
die kommentare waren hier drauf gekommen
seid also schreibt zum beispiel die
kommentare so drei minuten 33 und dann
halt peterle oder vier minuten 51 barack
obama wie auch immer aber leute ich weiß
dank euch auch dass ich jetzt jemand
eigenes alter eingeben muss gut an sich
ist eine figur sich youtube berühmt
geworden
ja kein tor heraus ist eine figur ein
mensch mit deine figur minecraft ja da
keine figur langes haar nein spielt
deine figur ins ist kein holz steger
spielfiguren skip fügen ins depot film
wirklich den jahr an alter akinator
jetzt mal lieber ein deutschkurs belegen
soll ist zwar kein deutsch einig müssen
dann sagen fleißig einkommen sind
beliebt sie ihm und sagen nein ist eine
figur congo after he was wenn man ja
antwortet locker noch eine frage
garantiert so was mal ausprobieren
also meine figur ist nicht von crafter
aber erstmal aus ja
ist die begrüßen der figur morgen
verbessern okay dann machen wir das
wieder zurück bloß nicht konkreter macht
eine figur minecraft crash mit nein
eur 2 nein war seine figuren ein
über eine million abonnenten nein warum
3 mit das ist jetzt die grosse frage
leute das ist jetzt die große frage war
diese person bei war u3 oder nicht
glaube man müsste sagen nein weiß die
personen damals auch nicht gab
eigentlich eine irgendwie schon
andererseits aber noch nicht also gab er
so drauf kommt eine figur aus der gruppe
an eine figur sneakers eis mich da auch
nicht mehr wie oft in action film mit
welche youtube figur spielt oft eine
exzellente jemand schreibt meine
kommentare ich kenne niemanden deswegen
sitzt in frage schon ist eine figur
adebayor deine figur ihr name pocken und
dran
nein figuren gerne gurken so alles klar
natürlich akinator du sollst fragen
stellen die zum ziel führen okay ist das
klar mach deine augen auf die scheiß
peter kann hierdurch sein geist
akihito ist immer noch ein akinator geld
und der stoffwechsel ist eine figur die
gurken noch so akinator geist hat sich
verabschiedet die figur ist nicht gerne
wochen wird eine figur lucky blogs ist
schon gemacht sie macht sich allzu oft
erwarte schon gemacht ich frage mich
etwas zu schwer ist für ihn ein super
mario maker nicht reiter in figuren ein
und eine figur in hamburg wilhelmsburg
dahin in deutschland geboren ja wobei
einfalt wald wald falsch falsch nein
nein er von einer die nato unter last
nicht gepackt die rückserie in einer
kleinen einheit meine figur ist nicht in
der liste an wen denkst du leute und
jetzt ist die letzte gelegenheit zu
schreiben was ihr glaubt ein wenig
gedacht habe wenn ich raten wollte
natürlich geht es im jahr die leute und
jan gab es 23 noch nicht deswegen die
frage aber eigentlich gab es hier schon
weil ich bin ja ja aber dann auch wieder
nicht weil jan es sich die lavant sache
oder bin ich doch jan schreibt man die
kommentare ob sie an bei wago drei schon
gab
auf jeden fall kann man auf alter ego
von sk ihr könnt ab jetzt jan
hoffentlich auch akinator nicht weiß es
nicht ob jetzt mal aus schickt mir gerne
aufs futter bilder ob das funktioniert
hat ist irgendwie sk dann aber auch
wieder nicht
yahoo
das schreiben wir nicht ran wir wollen
niemanden beleidigen aus china
seit wann gibt es jan wir schon mal
ihren geboren oder es richtig müssen
informationen reinpacken hier stets
leute
jan wurde am 12 10 2015 geboren am 12 10
2015 geboren
ok abschicken 250 buchstaben zu lang am
12 10 215 geboren
ein teil von ea so ok damit ist die
beschreibung ready abschicken
bravo sie haben eine falle gestellt ich
habe dir gezeigt junge du wusstest es
nicht man das war es vom heutigen video
das gerne daumen nach oben da will ich
das auch gefallen hat und schreibe noch
vorschlägen kommentare winter kommen
könnte wir sind von nächsten video
wieder haut rein macht gut und essen
weithin gurken pizza